we begin today with developing news from
downtown las vegas las vegas fire and
rescue
investigating a fire at a boarded up
school this noon hour
started around eight o'clock this
morning off bridger and 13th street
that's close to maryland parkway and
fremont street bianca holman is there
live on scene to tell us more on how
that started hi bianca
it took crews about 15 minutes to
contain this fire for those familiar
with this building
it's actually the old saint joseph
catholic school however it's been empty
for some time
once the first unit arrived on scene
they immediately called for backup
the fire was in the attic of this
one-story building smoke could be seen
coming from the roof
since the school has been abandoned for
some time their utilities were turned
off
the fire department tells us squatters
were seen leaving the building
we asked fire officials about any
potential charges
that's up the metro you know they have
to see them doing something
and a lot of times you can't charge
those people with arson
because it has to be intentional and
many times with squatters it's
accidental
either smoking cooking the same thing
that people do in their homes
now there were no injuries however
firefighters helped one person out of
the building
and now that hot spots are contained in
this building
investigators will be able to go inside
to determine the cause and also the
amount of damages
caused by the fire reporting from near
13th and brigidiere bianca holman
8 news now